We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The 2009 Feltron Annual Report. From this moment on, I want you to record every encounter you have with another person. Total encounters.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内进行合作与创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。2009年费尔特隆（Feltron）年度报告。从这一刻起，我希望你记录下你与他人进行的每一次接触。总接触次数。
Each mode of transportation. Methods of transportation. 23. Like, if I walk through the door, I'm writing down the name of that door. Total locations reported. 258. I just want to know every single place that I go. That's Nicholas Felton, aka Beltron.
每种交通方式。交通方式。23。比如，如果我走进一扇门，我会写下那扇门的名字。报告的总地点数。258。我只是想知道我去的每一个地方。那是尼古拉斯·费尔顿（Nicholas Felton），又名贝尔特隆（Beltron）。
I'm just trying to build a super rich data set. Data sets that he will interrogate at the end of the year, designing pie charts and bar graphs that are used to create a concise infographic that tells the story of Nicholas Felton's year. Is it going to be through the lens of like my favorite ETM or is it going to be through the person I spend the most time with? Most encounters with one person, 226. He calls the beautifully designed result, the Feltron Annual Report. Well, the thing that's really relatable about this report, that is the voice of freelance journalist Nate Berg. He interviewed Felton in New York for us. Not only is it clear and kind of easy to understand in the sort of graphs and pie charts that we've all gotten used to seeing all over the place,
我只是想建立一个超级丰富的数据集。他将在年底审视这些数据集，设计饼图和条形图，用于创建一份简洁的信息图表，讲述尼古拉斯·费尔顿这一年的故事。它是会通过我最喜欢的ETM的视角，还是通过我花时间最多的人的视角？与一个人接触最多，226次。他将这个设计精美的结果称为“费尔特隆年度报告”。嗯，这份报告真正让人产生共鸣的地方在于，这是自由撰稿人内特·伯格（Nate Berg）的声音。他为我们在纽约采访了费尔顿。它不仅清晰，而且在某种程度上很容易理解，因为我们都已经习惯在各处看到各种图表和饼图，
but I mean, it's presenting stuff directly kind of out of my own life, too. New York restaurants visited 111. How many restaurants did I go to last year? How many beers did I drink? Ice cream flavors consumed 9. These are all things that I do when having the data and the ability to present it helps draw that connection between two essentially strangers. All the easy dismissive criticisms about four square check-ins and Twitter should be popping into your mind right now. They all boil down to this.
但我的意思是，它也直接呈现了我自己生活中的东西。访问过的纽约餐厅，111家。我去年去了多少家餐厅？我喝了多少杯啤酒？消耗的冰淇淋口味，9种。这些都是我做的事情，拥有数据和展示数据的能力有助于在两个本质上陌生的人之间建立联系。所有关于Foursquare签到和Twitter的简单轻蔑的批评现在都应该浮现在你的脑海中。它们归根结底都是这样。
Why do I care about what you had for breakfast this morning? And I get that. But a funny thing happens when you take what you had for breakfast this morning and multiply it by a hundred of its quotidian equivalents and multiply that times 365. He's doing exactly what everyone else is doing, but he's just doing it in a more purposeful way. It's not only that he wants to track what's happening and kind of see how his life changes over time, but presented in a way that's digestible to himself and other people, even strangers. What Nicholas Felden creates with all that sprawling information
我为什么要关心你今天早上吃了什么早餐？我明白这一点。但当你把你今天早上吃的东西乘以一百个类似的日常琐事，再乘以365天时，一件有趣的事情发生了。他做的正是其他人都在做的事情，但他只是以一种更有目的性的方式在做。这不仅是因为他想跟踪正在发生的事情，并观察他的生活如何随时间变化，而且是以一种对他自己和其他人（甚至是陌生人）来说都易于消化和理解的方式呈现出来。尼古拉斯·费尔顿用所有这些庞杂的信息创造了什么
superficially resembles a corporate quarterly report, but it's the most beautiful version of that that you could possibly imagine, a true work of art. Most consecutive exclamation marks used, eight. 2008 was pretty boring year, I didn't travel very much. So the highlights were like first ice cream of the year, but it's this elaborate piece of design work that took weeks to create and cost thousands of dollars to produce to document this like one tiny memory that would have been totally lost otherwise It's my favorite way of telling stories now
表面上看起来像一份企业季度报告，但它是你能想象到的最美的版本，是一件真正的艺术品。连续使用的感叹号最多，8个。2008年是相当无聊的一年，我没有怎么旅行。所以亮点就像是这一年的第一个冰淇淋，但这件精心设计的工作花费了数周时间创作，耗资数千美元制作，以记录下这个本来会完全丢失的微小记忆。这是我现在最喜欢的讲故事方式
It's this way of making things that are either invisible or too large to be Comprehended making them visible rather than the abstractions of looking at tables of numbers. There's a pretty compelling and memorable ways of revealing invisible stories. It puts more focus on the little things that make up most of your time. Your life isn't really that trip that you took last summer. It's, you know, like the countable times that you walk down the same way to get to your office at one house in the corner
这是一种让那些不可见或太大而无法理解的事物变得可见的方法，而不是通过查看数字表格的抽象方式。这是一种非常引人注目且令人难忘的揭示隐形故事的方式。它将更多的注意力放在了占据你大部分时间的琐事上。你的生活其实并不是你去年夏天的那次旅行。而是，你知道，比如你每天走同样的路去办公室，在拐角处的那所房子，那些可数的次数
with that crazy dog. How many hours of your life have you spent listening to hotel California on the radio? I have to break in here to say this is where a normal public radio show would play the song Hotel California, but I am your friend, and I would never do that to you. That's the beauty of this kind of representation, is you can take something that represents millions or even billions of actions and reduce it to something that's consumable.
还有那只疯狂的狗。你一生中有多少小时是在收音机里听《加州旅馆》（Hotel California）度过的？我必须插一句，这是普通公共广播节目会播放《加州旅馆》这首歌的地方，但我是一个朋友，我永远不会那样对你。这种表现形式的美妙之处在于，你可以将代表数百万甚至数十亿次行动的事物简化为可消费的东西。
Average Waters per day, 0.24. Average beers per day, 0.99. Average beers per day, 0.99. Fulton has been doing this in-depth self-reporting since 2005, but at the end of 2010, his father died. And so the 2010 annual report took on a whole new scope. He took kind of that same approach, but applied it, you know, on a much grander scale to someone's entire life, the life of his father. The 2010 Feltron Annual Report. I didn't want my 2010 report to be the story of my father's death. I think his death is the least interesting part of his life story. Items cataloged.
平均每天喝水，0.24杯。平均每天喝啤酒，0.99杯。平均每天喝啤酒，0.99杯。费尔顿从2005年开始进行这种深入的自我报告，但在2010年底，他的父亲去世了。因此，2010年的年度报告采用了全新的范围。他采用了类似的方法，但将其应用在更宏大的规模上，针对一个人的整个人生，即他父亲的一生。2010年费尔特隆年度报告。我不想让我的2010年报告成为我父亲去世的故事。我认为他的去世是他人生故事中最不有趣的部分。编目的项目。
4,348. So I wanted to make something that talked about his life. Passport stamps, 239. It's like writing a biography about someone who's just in a different format, I think. And perhaps a more valid one, one that's more rooted in the facts, right? It is like a direct translation, there's very little, very little of my opinion that shows up in here. It's further back, it's in the editing, it's in the curation that my opinion shows up.
4,348件。所以我想要制作一些讲述他一生的东西。护照印章，239个。我认为这就像是为某人写传记，只是格式不同。也许是一种更有效的方式，一种更扎根于事实的方式，对吧？这就像是一个直接的翻译，这里面几乎没有我的观点。它更靠后，在编辑和策划中，我的观点才显现出来。
Postcards received 169. Photos of Gordon in record, 93. Percentage of photos of Gordon wearing a tie, 18%. It's his life story, so it's bookended by his birth and sadly by his death, but you know, that's one of the things I want to remember about him, and I think it's part of his story is that's the day he died, and that was what the weather was like, was the next statistic. I'm not trying to be shocking about it, but it needs to be in there.
收到的明信片，169张。记录中戈登（Gordon）的照片，93张。戈登戴领带的照片百分比，18%。这是他的人生故事，所以以他的出生和不幸的去世为书挡，但你知道，这是我想记住关于他的事情之一，我认为这是他故事的一部分，那就是他去世的那天，以及那天的天气如何，这是下一个统计数据。我并不是想对此感到震惊，但它需要包含在里面。
And I wanted to have a little repose at the end where you could sort of just absorb the end of his narrative. Last day, September 12th, 2010. I didn't want to dwell on sickness or his spirit fading. I think that's in there. If you look at a lot of the graphs, you can see a decline in meals out. It's kind of foreshadowed throughout the document that the spring has stepped.
我想在最后留一点休息时间，让你能够吸收他叙述的结尾。最后一天，2010年9月12日。我不想沉溺于疾病或他精神的消逝。我想那在里面。如果你看很多图表，你可以看到外出就餐的减少。这在整个文件中都有预示，春天已经过去了。
It was diminished in his last few years. My challenge was to try and take that idea of a biography and put it in a new form that I hadn't seen before. And, you know, you have to give up on not seeing him smile, like not seeing him in motion, not hearing his voice or, you know, listening to one of his jokes. But that's part of the aggregate view, that's part of this, this grander scope that I was going for. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Nate Berg and me Roman Mars. You can find Nate Berg's work at NateHeifenberg.com. I should also mention here that the voice of data in this piece was done by the lovely
他在最后几年里身体状况有所下降。我的挑战是尝试采用传记的理念，并将其放入一种我以前从未见过的新形式中。而且，你知道，你必须放弃看不到他微笑，看不到他运动，听不到他的声音，或者听不到他讲笑话。但这是总体视图的一部分，这是我所追求的更宏大范围的一部分。《99%隐形》本周由内特·伯格和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。你可以在 NateHeifenberg.com 找到内特·伯格的作品。我还应该在这里提到，这篇作品中数据的声音是由可爱
and talented Missed Is May Mars. The show 99% Invisible was made possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW, 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco, in the center for architecture and design. To find out more, including links to the Feltron website and the annual reports which you really do have to see, go to 99%invisible.org. Hello everyone, it's Roman Mars again. I just wanted to welcome a bunch of new people
且有才华的米斯特·伊兹·梅·马尔斯（Missed Is May Mars）完成的。《99%隐形》节目的制作得到了 Lunar 的支持，用创造力创造差异。这是旧金山当地公共广播电台 KALW 91.7、旧金山美国建筑师协会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。欲了解更多信息，包括费尔特隆网站和年度报告的链接（你真的必须看看），请访问 99%invisible.org。大家好，我是罗曼·马尔斯。我只是想欢迎一群新朋友
to the 99th percentile because iTunes has been featuring the show on the big banner and the iTunes podcast store. So thanks to them, they were so great. I think we've got a bunch of new people thanks to that little quote from Jad of them, Rod of Radio Lab encouraging people to check out the show and the prime placement. So thanks for checking us out and I just want to let you know that all the old episodes of Nine Emperes and Abyssalville, first of all, they're all pretty good, some are better than others, but they're all pretty good and they're all what we call evergreen in the radio business. So they're not pegged any certain date, the information isn't too old or doesn't get deprecated very fast, so just download them all, check check them out and I hope you enjoy them.
加入到第99百分位，因为 iTunes 一直在 iTunes 播客商店的大横幅上推荐这个节目。所以感谢他们，他们太棒了。我想我们因为 Radio Lab 的贾德（Jad）鼓励人们查看这个节目的一小段引语以及黄金位置，吸引了一群新朋友。所以感谢你们的关注，我只是想让你们知道，所有《99%隐形》的旧剧集，首先，它们都相当不错，有些比其他的更好，但它们都相当不错，而且它们都是我们在广播行业所说的“常青”内容。所以它们没有固定在任何特定的日期，信息也不会太旧或过时得很快，所以把它们都下载下来，看看吧，希望你们喜欢。
Also I want to thank all the folks who've already done iTunes reviews. I put a call out for these, we got tons of them, we're going to pantalysically close to getting 300 ratings and reviews, which I'm really psyched for and you wouldn't believe how much they helped, they just they help tremendously and it's just very very kind and very sweet and people have been writing very, very nice things. Thank you so much. It's been fantastic. Alright, I think that's it for this week. So if you want to get in touch, you can always follow us on Facebook.
此外，我要感谢所有已经进行 iTunes 评论的人。我发出了这些呼吁，我们收到了大量的评论，我们非常接近获得300个评分和评论，我对此感到非常兴奋，你无法相信它们有多大的帮助，它们提供了巨大的帮助，而且非常非常友善和贴心，人们写了很多非常非常好的东西。非常感谢。这太棒了。好了，我想本周就是这样。所以如果你想联系我们，你可以随时在 Facebook 上关注我们。
I put some stuff there that I don't always put on the blog, so maybe you want to join on Facebook. You follow me on Twitter if you like your 9-inch and invisible news. I've heard with a bunch of nonsense for me in my personal life, that's at Roman Mars, or you can just leave a comment on the blog, that would be fantastic. I'd love to hear from you. Alright, take care, and I'll talk to you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我在那里放了一些我不总是放在博客上的东西，所以也许你想加入 Facebook。如果你喜欢《99%隐形》的新闻，可以在 Twitter 上关注我。我听说我个人生活中的一堆废话，那是 @RomanMars，或者你也可以在博客上留言，那将非常棒。我很乐意收到你的来信。好了，保重，我们下周再聊。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。